alright guys I'm super excited about
this episode we've got a Marco here
you've been in crypto for a really long
time and you've got all kinds of
interesting perspectives so thank you so
much for coming and sharing with us
thanks for having me I'm glad to be here
absolutely all right
so for those though they don't know
let's just go through a quick background
on you and then we can talk about how
how you originally got into crypto early
on yeah happy to do it so my name is
Marco Santori I'm the president chief
legal officer at blockchain blockchain
is the world's largest software platform
for digital assets though you probably
you probably know us because of the
wallet you probably know us because we
have almost 30 million wallets all that
today we may have actually crossed that
mark but 30 million wallets all around
the world we aren't like an exchange
we're not like the custodial providers
we are a place where you don't really go
to speculate you go to actually use this
stuff and go to to hold and bot to hold
and send and actually you know use
functional crypto currencies got it and
so let's talk about pre blockchain right
so your 2011-2012 originally discovered
crypto yeah 2012 late late 2012 I helped
form a currency trading fund for people
who were they weren't doing anything
interesting they were like shorting the
Euro or something and but at the end of
the day you know they they joke with me
and they say Oh Marco you know ha ha ha
well really doing is trading crypto well
back then they just said Bitcoin and
back then it was it was a joke there
really weren't that many people trading
Bitcoin certainly not successfully but
they refer to client to me who actually
was and that person referred somebody to
me and the person referred somebody to
me and I started posting on Bitcoin talk
if you've ever been a Bitcoin talk you
can still see the tweets they are
they're totally cringe-worthy it's lino
hi my name is Marko Santori and I'm a
lawyer and I want to learn more about
Bitcoin epic and and the word got out
there was a lawyer than what there was a
lawyer in Bitcoin and well then I was
the chairman of the regulatory affairs
committee for the Bitcoin
Foundation Peck Lynette back when that
was a thing I was the among the first
team of I think five or six of us who
went down to DC and explained to the
federal government
this is Bitcoin this is how it works
this is this is the blockchain and we
and we actually projected a copy of
blockchain back then blockchain dot e
info mm-hmm up on the screen and took
them through a transaction and said this
is a Bitcoin address it has an
Associated private key you know and and
took him through the whole thing and the
look of wonder and confusion and
discussed in some of these regulators
and policymakers faces back in 2013 it's
something that that has stuck with me
for a long time but after that I was a
partner at Pillsbury and a partner at
coulee two global law firms where Matt
Cooley I worked on the on the shaft
project framework which we published
with protocol labs and then recently I I
left private practice I I would I
I caught the virus as you like to say
and I went all in crypto and I'm oh now
I'm the chief legal officer at
blockchain so what's fascinating to me
is in 2013 the federal government right
is actually listening to private
citizens describe a digital currency
what it is how it works what the
advantages disadvantages are etc and
this is really before most people in
crypto today even knew what this stuff
was so the federal government actually
pretty far ahead in terms of at least
being aware and hearing about it but it
sounds like they weren't very receptive
right so they were listening but maybe
they weren't actually hearing what was
going on well so to start from the from
from from from the first principle the
US was in 2013 and and remains the
farthest ahead on crypto policy almost
anywhere in the world and and that's a
that's a crazy thing to hear
and certainly crazy thing for me to say
because I can't say that about a lot of
places in US policy but crypto is one of
those places where the US federal
government got this stuff it understood
the what this stuff can do and took
reasonable approaches to it but
or any any government did and now we
have Japan with a license South Korea
considering a license some some places
some smaller countries geographically
smaller have jumped ahead because they
can move faster right but here in the US
we've got a federal government plus we
have fifty four well fifty three other
sovereigns that we have to deal with so
things can move a little bit more slowly
here and it has it's been a long
conversation but you know I got I got I
have to say so far the federal
government has has not taken crazy
positions on crypto yeah they've
actually been very measured they're
taking their time to understand this
stuff and especially when you compare
them to you know China or other
jurisdictions where you know one week
they're banning something that next week
they're not and just the uncertainty I
think is one thing right so if you don't
know what the position is
that's the risk that you're have to deal
with but I think it's even worse when
there is kind of the the jarring or
chaos of the regulation actually
changing on a pretty consistent or
frequent basis yeah absolutely and today
right everyone's talking about the SEC
and the CFTC and I have my thoughts on
on why that is and how that happened but
back in 2013 nobody nobody was talking
about the SE C's involvement in crypto
or the CFTC's involvement in crypto and
not just because you know certain
internal champions and those agencies
weren't there yet but really because
Bitcoin was just money and that's all
there was was so what were people
talking about race oh they're not
talking about securities they're not
time what kind of all of the things that
are being talked about today what was
that conversation was it just I want to
understand or and I'm a regular and I
want to understand this stuff or was it
some deeper conversation there there
were two things that regulators were
worried about one money laundering you
wanted to make sure that the illicit
activity wasn't happening on these
financial networks and there weren't any
black holes where the government didn't
have didn't have visibility the second
thing was Prudential concerns they
wanted to make sure that at the end of
the day your uncle or your aunt or
whomever you were sending money to got
their money yeah those are the two very
different concerns under the law and the
federal government mostly was concerned
with preventing illicit activity
money laundering the states mostly don't
play in that sandbox they're there
they're there they're not concerned with
AML with the exception of New York and
maybe a little bit in Arizona states are
mostly concerned with making sure that
the people who are supposed to who were
who are supposed to get their money at
the end of the day like in the case of
like MoneyGram or Western Union get
their money at the end of the day so it
was two very very different different
concerns competing against each other
and of course crypto entrepreneurs con
the middle absolutely and you know last
question about this but when you guys go
down and you have these conversations
why some follow-up conversation or
whatever and you guys leave what's the
feeling among the pro crypto private
citizens right is it man this is really
depressing these people don't care is it
frustration do you leave actually
encouraged kind of what was that
reaction to those meetings and
conversations it depends on you speak to
that when you're on social media and
you're reading about the next thing
happening in crypto in DC it always
seems to be something yep but in reality
nobody in DC is talking about crypto
there's very few people there there's
very few people who are concerned with
it there are very few people that that
it's on the radar
there are staffers that are very deep in
this stuff but there's maybe a dozen of
them on the hill there are great policy
shops like coin Center there are new
trade organizations forming but as far
as regulators and policy makers well I
should say as far as policy makers go
like the legislature right Congress not
a whole lot of discussion about this
stuff there's a few different bills
pending but in the day to day it's not
very popular regulators though there's a
point there when you know half of some
of these agencies resources were
dedicated to making a statement in this
industry mm-hmm do you think that the
policy makers aren't focused on it
because it's like an opportunity cost so
there's just so much other things going
on that this is so small today compared
to the other stuff
that's that's really all there is I mean
over the last over the last few years
we've entered a period of political
discourse in this country that is
overshadowed so much of the rest of our
public
wives that you know crypto hasn't been
as high on the radar as it could have
been mm-hmm okay so that's super
interesting right because basically
clients brought you Bitcoin you start
kind of understanding it etc what was
the reaction inside of the law firms at
the time right so it's the policymakers
you know that I got that that was kind
of a natural reaction from them the law
firms you know these are clients right
you're supposed to be trying to help
them accomplish their business goals and
things like that but are there people at
that law firm that are you know this
stuff is illegal and we should not play
in it it was everyone pretty Copa minded
what was that maybe I was really lucky
but each of the three law firms that I
worked at that had where I had a crypto
practice were encouraging supportive
they wanted me to do more they were
happy that I was out when I was you know
when I was first starting out in crypto
they were kind of surprised that he now
had like a FinTech practice right we we
went from litigating these laws to
actually advising on them which is a
jump that you know not all lawyers make
and then by the time I got to Cooley I
mean we had built one of the biggest
practices in the industry and it was
sort of a thought leadership practice
and a lot of ways and and there were
there were risks around that and that
you know people there are there are
always people who don't want who don't
want to upset things who they don't want
to upset the applecart but I got to tell
you there were very few of those in the
law firms I worked at and and by the
time I got to Cooley we were we were all
just thrilled to be able to do this kind
of work the kind of work that most
lawyers never get to do absolutely all
right so as you're kind of working
through you know a couple of years there
I SEOs utility tokens and eventually the
saft all pop up because previously they
just been Bitcoin only right and so now
we get to oh there's Bitcoin and there's
this other stuff what's kind of your
early experience with icos and the idea
of utility token or non Bitcoin type you
know assets you know back in 2013 we
just called this stuff Bitcoin 2.0 and
there nobody was talking about crypto
generally the cryptographers were not
yet up in arms for losing their their
their precious crypto namesake to the to
the cryptocurrency people the the
thought was that maybe one day you'll be
able to use Bitcoin for something other
than money that was that was the
baseline thought that you know you can
we call these entries in the blockchain
they call them bitcoins but are they UT
EXO is you know what are they they're
nothing they're just entries that we had
that we happen that are scarce and we
happened to call them money and there
was a thought that one day it could be
more than that there was a thought that
you could use these entries you could
call them something else and so the
first one of the first implementations
of that was something called colored
coins which is a unfortunate name I
think but the idea being that you could
color if you can imagine a coin a
physical coin you could color it in
purple right after you've taken it out
of the bag of coins and throw it back
into the bag you'd always be able to
trace it no matter where it went
those were no longer fungible sort of
non fungible coins now we call those NF
T's non fungible tokens when we
implement them on etherium but back then
that was still like sci-fi that that was
science fiction and there were similar
implementations of that like mat that
was colored coins master coin and what
were people using the colorful coins
right so somebody comes up with hey we
should color the coins and and kind of
create these non fungible assets but
what was the thought process behind
creating them I think it was mostly
experimentation these people didn't
really know where the meets and bounds
were they didn't know what this was
gonna be what applications what use
cases this was gonna be good for so the
the the the simple ability to do it was
kind of mind-blowing mm-hmm yeah it's
super interesting how some of these
ideas already in a short you know five
six years cycle have already kind of
gone away and come back right so non
fungible tokens being a prime example of
you know it's popular in 2013/2014 they
go away then all sudden they come
roaring back back by bc's you know and
kind of now the new hot raging thing
again and maybe they're not snows people
kind of aversion I thought all right so
let's talk about icos and the utility
tokens right so we go from the colored
coins to eventually somebody says hey
I'm going to create a new block chain
that has differences or improvements to
it and I'm gonna raise capital for it
via a new funding mechanism what is the
the reaction there you know from your
perspective well I think that the
fundamental innovation was that people
realized it was more than just Bitcoin
mm-hmm and if you know people ask me why
I think the price run up of 2017
happened and I usually tell them I don't
have a whole lot of thoughts on price I
don't have a whole lot of thoughts on on
on speculation and but this is one of
those exceptions and then I I do know
why that run-up happened and that's
because people realize there was more to
this than just Bitcoin and that's not to
diminish the impact of Bitcoin it's to
highlight the public perception around
the industry and so when people started
to realize there was more to this than
just this one asset this this one money
that people that some people preferred
to government money for certain for
certain applications I think that
expanded a lot of people's minds they
started to realize oh my gosh this
technology is actually really
encompassing it could it could change
almost everything that we do and look it
sounds trite now but the introduction of
smart contracts changed the way that
people think about blockchains it was no
longer chains were no longer just a
vehicle for like libertarian money all
right they were a vehicle for
implementing business logic in a
trustless way and that meant a lot of
different things that for example you
know for example creating tokenized
assets but also being too programmatic
but also being able to programmatically
do things with those assets in a way
that you never had
really trust some central intermediary
that that brought the power of Bitcoin
outside of just the world of money and
into the world of well anything that has
a value absolutely and so where's the
SAFF come out of this right so there's
protocol Labs come to you guys and say
we need some sort of standardized
documentation in order to empower the
funding of all this is this something
where you guys are working with a single
client and say well we need to make sure
that we're really thoughtful about this
kind of how does that originate from an
idea and then eventually how you go and
build it
well protocol labs came to me his client
and my advise them on on a number of
different on a number of different
matters and one of them was the the sale
of this instrument that people were
using we didn't invent it people were
using this thing called a shaft simple
agreement for future tokens which was of
course just a simple agreement for
future equity that somebody had held
held down control impressed eff and
replaced some equity with tokens so
originally there's no there's really no
innovation other than swapping out the
word activity that's it that's the end
of the conversation no we we saw this
thing and we thought wow this is a lot
of people are using this and it's it's
it's kind of toxic in a lot of ways if
if you look at this document there it
just didn't make a whole lot of
operational sense and the way that the
way that people were using it that said
we had this notion that maybe it it
could if we used it correctly and so you
have to understand the shaft in context
well the shaft project in context it was
the first self regulatory reaction to
this rash of pre functional token sales
which people colloquially called AI cos
initial coin offerings people came up
with a bigger and better aetherium or a
bigger and better Bitcoin something they
thought was gonna be better than what's
out there and in order to raise money
what they were doing was just selling
that's a very basic token which was you
if you're familiar with the expression
can of trading sardines it didn't
actually do anything the sardines were
actually good for eating they were just
good for trading and so it gave rise to
speculative frenzy that when we looked
at this we thought wow that who's
actually investor protection and risks
involved in these pre functional token
sales we think that these aren't just
you know consumer goods they're people
that are buying these things for
speculation
I'm nothing wrong with that but you know
there are laws about things that are
buying people who are buying speculative
goods that are reliant on the efforts of
the issuer of that good they're the
securities laws and so the saft project
well I should say this this after
framework generally says look you can
use this very simple document you should
negotiate it it should include the
additional investor protections that you
want and that you should apportion risk
but at the end of the day you should use
it and sell it as a security because
that's that's what the thing is when
someone buys this document this saft
well they're buying it with the
expectation of profit from the efforts
of others from the efforts of the issuer
and if you know in the united states
that is of course the how we test for
for what what is an investment contract
and therefore security but then once
those tokens once those tokens work once
they actually are put to their intended
purpose once once anyone who buys them
is no longer reliant on the efforts of
the person who issued it well I mean
there are risks there but they're not
investor risks are they there they're
like the risks of someone who buys a
used car like yeah maybe the engine
doesn't work but that's not because
someone failed to expend their efforts
and so you need disclosures around like
their finances like it who cures a Ford
goes bankrupt next year the question is
does my engine work and so there there
are consumer protection laws that you
should apply at that point so that that
that was the that was the breakdown of
the of this after framework and we
released the South project white paper
around this time last year and about a
month later we stopped seeing ICL's in
the United States the saft framework for
better or for worse became a market
standard in the US yeah it you've used a
terminology pre functional token sale
right or pre functioning token sale
and my guests that you're using that in
in a very intentional way because that
describes a token having to do that how
he tasks and things compared to if I
just go on you know a coin base and buy
Bitcoin for example right
where do regulators in the United States
right now from your perspective shakeout
on the difference between that pre
functioning token and then the
circulating or functioning token you
know on a network I'd say like an
aetherium today where we are yeah so
after we released after we published the
white paper a month later the ICO
started to kind of trickle off and
disappear and then a few months while
several months after that actually just
just this summer the the director of the
division of corporation finance at the
SEC gave a speech which was not
officially the SEC spurred the SE C's
position
it isn't law and it's it's it's not even
binding on the SEC but he said look
there's been a lot of talk around what
is and isn't a security in the world of
crypto here's what I think personally
and what he said is important but it's
also important how he said it right and
then he he says look this it
this isn't law but look realistically
the head of the the director of the
division of corporation finance is a
pretty important guy and it's up to him
and his official capacity to determine
what is it is not a security from the SE
C's perspective and this is what he said
he said yeah you're pre functional post
functional distinction is right but it's
actually not the whole story there's
there's more to it there's a question
there's there's there's a whole litany
of things there's a whole litany of
questions you can ask to try to figure
out where your risk of being a security
is and some of those things included how
many people actually own a token is it
just concentrated in the hands of a few
people a few whales right that are gonna
dump on a bunch of retail investors
later did you sell it
using speculative language you try to
whip up a frenzy with a countdown timer
and you know all these things we see in
ICS and and there's there's a few more
you can you can you can
get out you can check out the text of
the speech online but you know I think
people today are still are still they
still want more I personally think we've
we've gotten as much as as as we could
really ask for in such a difficult
determination but SEC has said recently
I think just just yesterday or two days
ago I should say bill Hinman again the
director of the division of corporation
finance just said actually you know what
we gave you a lot we gave you this
heuristic this sort of you know this
this fuzzy this fuzzy list of questions
to help you think about this we're gonna
give you some plain English guidance and
I don't know when that will come I I
don't think anybody I may be the SEC
itself doesn't even know precisely when
it'll come but it's an important
question and it's not wrong that they've
taken their time to answer it yeah and
he made it sound when he said this that
it's near-term that could be weeks
months you know I don't think to your
point anyone really actually knows but
it sounded like the way I read it is
they hear that people are saying we want
more clarity yeah right some of that's
coming from institutional investors some
of that's coming from projects that want
to actually you know kind of push the
envelope in a compliant way but but I do
think it's interesting he has kind of
led the charge some of the public
comments right given where you know he
sits in the organization how does the
SEC and other Western North American
regulators compared to the rest of the
world right so we talked about their
approach in terms of they're definitely
more tempered and and kind of patient
and maybe focused on learning first
before they actually act but from an
actual regulatory guidance standpoint do
they look at it differently or is it
just there are approaches different but
everyone's coming to the same conclusion
around this stuff yeah this is this is
more question about the law than it is
about the regulator's who interpret and
apply the law okay because in the in the
United States the SEC you know isn't
isn't a judge they're not they're not
the courts they are plaintiffs mm-hm
now they're much more powerful than
other plaintiffs right but the question
is really about what is the law in the
US versus what is the law
and it's it's an important an important
question because when it comes to money
services laws like you know anti money
laundering and consumer protection and
that kind of thing everyone around the
world they're pretty uniform on this we
have something called the fat of the
financial action task force that ensures
that harmony and commonality among those
laws that doesn't I mean there are
analogous bodies in the world of
securities but in the US the the
perimeter that you draw around what is a
security is enormous as compared to the
rest of the world because we have this
notion of an investment contract which
doesn't exist in most other
jurisdictions there are things called
collective investment schemes in other
jurisdictions but they're much more
restrictive because of the jurisdictions
generally have what's called a positive
listing system they say look these eight
things or securities and they stopped in
the US we say these 30 things are
securities also there's this catch-all
called the investment contract then most
of these most of these tokens we argued
in in the white paper that we're sold
pursuant to icos well I should say in
most of these icos
there was an investment contract cream
they got it and so we'll come back to
this idea of an investment contract in a
second but before we do that let's talk
about blockchain in kind of your role
there right so you're in private
practice you've got all these clients
you're you know one of the foremost
thought leaders when it comes to
applying the existing laws to this new
technology new industry why leave what
why kind of get out of of the direct
legal private practice and go more on to
the operator side you know as as as you
like to say i i caught the virus and but
the thing is i I caught the virus in
2012 so ok you gotta tell the story
right so before the show we were talking
and I actually didn't know this says
everybody knows I've been using this
tagline the virus is spreading for a
while now and the thought process was
the idea of crypto was going viral right
and people were as they learned about it
they would tell their friends and just
kind of continued to permeate through
society but you said that
the word virus is not new to crypto and
so we can tell that story I I'm shocked
when I when I first saw you tweeting
about you know the virus is spreading I
assumed you were referring to what we
always used to say back in 2013 which
for 2012 for that matter that Bitcoin is
the mind virus once you once you catch
it it's actually tough to stop thinking
about it
not just because you know it's an
amazing invention and and and has and is
filled with so much possibility and
power but also because it starts to make
you question things that you always sort
of held as as obvious as axiomatic and
that's one of the one of the great
things about being a lawyer in this
space is you get to revisit first
principles mm-hmm most lawyers don't get
to do that they sit behind a desk and
like securitize the same over and over
again or they litigate the same kind of
case over and over again and we got to
make people think about money in a way
that they never did before I mean I'd
consider it a victory to get people to
think about something in a way that they
never really did before and Bitcoin did
that for all of us
yeah it's fun it is it's a blast
especially again for lawyers who aren't
really known for having fun job yeah all
right so you're there you get the the
mind virus or the virus spreads to you
and you leave and to talk a little bit
about what you're doing at blotching
today yeah so I you know I I worked with
a lot of different crypto companies over
the over my years in private practice
and I was in I was impressed by a great
many of them at the end of the day there
was one that was really fighting for the
things that I believed in individual
financial freedom taking taking
ownership and control of your money and
the exchanges weren't doing that
especially in 2017 what we saw was the
headlines start to shift toward you know
Lambos and when moon and and and stuff
like that and that's that it's it's it's
exciting and it's and it's part of what
has gotten a lot of people into crypto
but it wasn't for me right some some
some some people said
have said that bitcoin is a is a tool
for overthrowing all the guards and
decima it's wrapped up and again and
wrapped up and it get rich quick scheme
and that that may be the case I don't
know about overthrowing all the guards
and despots and all that but I I do know
that the get-rich-quick part of this of
that story started to pull so much of
the narrative away from why I was
involved in this in the first place
which was to give people control over
their finances in a way that they
couldn't achieve in the traditional
banking system I mean you know there
there there are people not just in this
world not just in this state but in this
zip code
who can't get a bank account without
being charged $15 a month for inactivity
fees it is it is expensive right to be
poor in this country and in much of the
world people don't use blockchain just
to speculate they don't use it to buy
something for a dollar and sell it for
two they use it so they can actually it
they can actually well use crypto so
that some people use use their
blockchain wallets too as as as their
primary banking source and you can and
you can do that we've we've done it and
we've supported it as successfully as we
can over the last years to the point
where now there's 30 million different
wallets doing doing that so the
difference between what blockchain does
and what most other exchanges for
example do is that well you have your
coins you have your private keys when
when you have coins on an exchange for
example and you want to send those coins
you want to use them you want to do
something with them if they're tokens
that run a decentralized application or
it's just Bitcoin and your coins are on
an exchange what you do is exactly what
you do with your bank you say dear Bank
dear exchange
can I please pretty please have my money
back and and you know what send it over
to Alice or Bob and sometimes the
exchange says No
that's not that's that's not why people
use use Bitcoin that's not why people
got into this in the first instance or
they say yes but only so much right yes
only so much right right so you can only
said $25,000 a day yep exactly and
blockchain from the beginning was it was
pure software and it still is we never
take custody of your funds we never take
control of your funds we give you
software so that you can interact
directly with the Bitcoin network if an
exchange gets hacked the wallet can get
emptied
if blockchain gets hacked we don't have
your money that's that's the difference
you can store the very same coins in a
blockchain wallet at the very same time
they are being stored in any number of
any of other industry standard software
wallets and spend them out from
underneath it that is that is that is
self custody that's what it means to
have control and power over your own
money and that's kind of the point right
so when I when I had the choice of which
which company to go to to to really
drive this forward I chose the one that
really instantiates the values that I
hold dear
yeah it's funny I've got a funny youth
euphemism and then I've got a serious
one but I say that most of our parents
grew up with sex drugs and rock and roll
right and then we grew up with Lambos
and moons so when you kind of think of
that like I don't know who's who's
winning on that trade yeah but I do
think the other thing you know look
we've we've got around the country and
we've been talking to everyone from
institutional investors down to family
offices high net worth individuals and
just kind of general what I would
consider the retail investors of crypto
and we all these events and in these
different cities and the thing that's
always struck me when people ask me
what's the most surprising thing
throughout all of those conversations
with different people it's how many
people actually believe and question the
very kind of core elements of crypto
right so they don't trust the
traditional banking system they have
questions about the fiat currency system
or the Federal Reserve right all of
these elements that I think a little
scary to think about it first right and
and they're probably not the first thing
that you're going to go and publicly
talk about until you're
really comfortable with your own
thoughts with your own opinions
you've had enough conversations but but
it's always shocked me at how many
people have the exact same feelings that
you just described where you had your
pick to go to all these companies and
you end up being attracted to the one
where it really is about financial
freedom it really is about you know a
different system or an alternative
system giving people choice yeah and so
I talked to investors actually about
this all the time not not people who
invest in crypto but I talked to like
venture capitalists your example all the
time and they say what's the difference
between you and the big exchanges out
there like why why should we invest in
you and not to make exchanges and you
know in my opinion that sometimes those
big exchanges are good investments but
there's a there's a market difference in
our customer base versus theirs their
customers go there to take their dollars
and turn them into more dollars put
dollars in there's a ticker that goes up
and down
you take your dollars out mm-hmm people
don't come to blockchain to do that
people come to blockchain to use their
money we provide liquidity services we
just launched lockbox and swap which is
a little bit it's actually nothing like
netflix and chill' but it it sounds like
it it's a lot less fun than netflix and
chill' but it does mean that you can
actually hold your own crypto in a
hardware wallet and when you want to
move between kryptos you can swap
between kryptos we do offer liquidity
services but at the end of the day
people don't come to blockchain
so that they can speculate they come to
blockchain so that they can use crypto
and that's and that's that's part of
what our airdrops program is all about
yeah absolutely well the other piece too
is I think at least when we talk with
folks who are a little bit older you
know from an age perspective they're
shocked when I start to describe you
know there's a demographic of people you
know younger people who they've got
double digit maybe mid double digit or
higher percentages of their net worth
and digital assets right and to them
it's not risky right it is of course
there's going to be digital money
digital stores of value of course I'm
gonna have a digital wallet and you know
kind of have this hybrid between a bank
accountant or
brokerage account and you know all this
kind of stuff that I think is new and
and different and possibly scary to
people who one don't understand it or to
grew up just having it beat into their
head that the Fiat system and
nutritional legacy banking system is
just the way it is and so I think the
work that you guys are doing is you're
really empowering that generation of
people who believe something different
to actually interact with the technology
in a way that keeps them in power but
but also reduces some of the risk of
doing it right in terms of the security
and things like that yeah it's
absolutely right and that's that's
that's that's the way that we see it too
I mean we we we could have taken the
company I think I say we by I joined in
February but I've been the company's
lawyer for the last four years and I you
know the the company could have gone in
any number of different directions but
they stayed the course in 2015 when
nobody was talking about public
blockchains and diamonds and everybody
was talking about DLT do you remember
DLT distributed laser technology it's
the term that the banks would come up
with to sanitize crypto as much as they
could to try to get to try to get their
boards on board but even back when
people were thinking about we're talking
about DLT blockchain never started doing
proofs of concept with banks whenever
that wasn't us that's just not the
vision that we had and it's not the
vision that we have today mm-hmm well
look it is the user base speaks for
itself right let me ask you this
question what do you think I remember
ask anybody this one but I think you've
kind of your perspectives very different
and you were kind of an outsider that
was friendly to the company for a while
and now are an insider what would you
say is the most legitimate criticism
people have of that approach right so
while everyone else is out working with
the banks and legacy system and they're
all trying to jockey for different kind
of advantages or ways to get ahead you
guys stayed the course and so there's
obviously people we're gonna disagree
with that approach what's the most
legitimate criticism of that I think
that the legitimate criticisms come from
time scale they say so when I say hey
when people ask me one is blockchain
gonna have went when is the man on the
street
going to have a blockchain wallet just
as just as surely as they have a
cellphone right
I give them a long time scale and that's
because it's actually difficult in this
country to explain to people that you
know the benefits of having control
having self having user controlled
wallets some people think it's risky
some people think that it's just not a
job they want to do you know what at the
end of the day I have a bank account you
know I have a credit card I respect that
I don't I don't I don't want to do that
work myself
but you know that's just here that's
just the u.s. blockchain isn't even a US
company right that's what most people
don't realize blockchain was founded in
not New York but York right we this this
this this is a very very old and very
international company we we were not us
first and you'll be surprised to learn
how much even after the events of 2008
you still trust your bank you still walk
up there you still give them your money
every day and you asked them pretty
please can I take it out and I asked the
same thing you know I I do the same
thing but in many parts of the world
that is that is not the case and it
shows in our numbers we we have plenty
of users in the United States but a
couple of months ago I was I was I was
the management team shared metrics with
me and it and we had signed on more
users from Kenya that month then we had
from Texas and you see that happen
occasionally because people in the rest
of the world well their banks have not
been good stewards of their money and
you could argue that's happened here in
the United States to where our money is
worth less and less every day but by and
large we've done our government has
actually done a very good job compared
to most of the world so it's why the
company decided that it was not going to
be why the company decided had to have
an international first approach yeah
well you're describing as this you know
good gets in the way of great right and
the US banking system is good enough for
a majority of people
to do a majority of the things that they
want to do yeah right and so you know
how many people have their their wealth
devalued away in the United States
financial system very little right how
many people have their capital seized or
their wealth seized very little right
how many people want to move money and
can't do it or the bank you know
restricts them from doing it
not very many right and so because the
financial system is good enough and
there's just enough infrastructure that
people can get by with it I think they
become complacent right they don't want
to aspire for the great thing that could
be possible that the base of the other
technology breaks yeah it's it's it's
not a uniquely American thing but it is
it is amplified here in the United
States and Western Europe places where
people have sound money relative to the
rest of the world right you use that
phrase sound money and the Mac and the
Bitcoin maximalist start to say what US
doesn't have sound money and well I mean
on a relative scale maybe gold is the
only thing that's truly pure right but I
certainly don't feel that way I'm I
don't count myself among them but then
you look at places like Japan which yeah
the money has not been spectacular there
but they have so many different kinds of
payment systems an adoption has been so
much quicker there for things like
contactless card 'less payments the rest
of the world is a big place absolutely
yeah and you know look we saw this in
African countries right I talk a lot
about this idea that citizens of African
countries had no banking infrastructure
maybe 20 years ago and they leapfrog the
US when it came to mobile banking right
it was just because they had nothing and
so all of a sudden I can text you money
yeah right it just became very popular
yeah like landlines landline phones
right it was just a stage they skipped
yep and so I think that we're seeing
some of that with this decentralized
kind of open finance or you know user
first type financial products in other
parts of the world right some you know
the classic examples are the Venezuela's
Argentina's in the world except true but
I think this is happening in Africa I
think it's happening across Asia
it's just places where they don't have
good enough infrastructure and so they
go from you know very bad to great
infrastructure it sokham take some time
but but in some ways they're they're
lucky that they're not distracted by the
good enough infrastructure yep right all
right so let's get back to watching it
real quick let's talk about air drops
right so obviously blockchain and the
securities world finance etc the
traditional markets are pretty well
understood there's been plenty of time
plenty of smart people who have looked
at all this stuff but the blockchain
ecosystem in crypto specifically bring
quite a number of nuances right so these
air drops hard Forks what is the company
blockchain right how do you guys look at
that and then talk about this airdrop
program that you guys create exciting
it's a pretty new and nuanced thing that
that's pretty powerful
well blockchain serves as the on-ramp
for millions and millions of people all
around the world one of the difficult
things about getting into crypto is
getting crypto you have to you have to
sign on to an exchange that might lose
your money you have to buy it and some
shady ico you have to mine it which is
difficult or you can be like me and I
actually earned my first crypto actually
like I accepted it for legal fees but
let me tell you that's hard actually
doing work for stuff is sometimes really
hard so we that look the there there
there can be a better way
and as you can tell for the theme of
this I've actually dedicated a lot of my
time to try to figure out better ways to
crypto adoption we did that with this
after project white paper we tried to
set icos aside and say there couldn't be
a better way and and this is another
this is this is another way to do it if
you want to invent the next Bitcoin or
the next aetherium or the next the
bigger and better thing to bigger and
better crypto network you're a creator
well at first you've got a bunch of
crypto and you want people to use it
one necessary but not sufficient
qualification requirement for getting
people to use it is them actually having
it so what an airdrop can do and I'll
is put crypto in the hands of many
people it can take crypto out of the
hands of just a few usually a few
creatives and put it in the hands of
many people the way that happens is that
well remember I said with blockchain you
have our our users anybody with a
blockchain wallet actually has the
private keys to their crypto they are
the ones who are in control of it not
some bank or intermediary financial
institution so what an airdrop that
Creator takes the crypto and gives it
away for free mm-hmm and if they do it
through blockchain they certainly don't
pay us any of it we don't keep any of it
we don't charge listing fees or anything
every every every piece of crypto we get
we give to our users we work for our
users and we did our we published a set
of guiding principles on airdrops
you can read that on our website at
blockchain comm it's easy to remember
you can read the guiding principles
there and today we actually announced
our first our very first airdrop our
very first implementation of those
guiding principles we're dropping
something called stellar stellar xlm
we're giving it away for free to our
users and it's all it's all starting now
all right so let's back up for a second
so the air drops are merely the creators
you know in over-generalized world if
the creators are giving away these
crypto assets right to everyone else
sometimes it's incentivize them to
participate in a network sometimes it's
money it could be a whole bunch of
different use cases but it's a giveaway
to some degree for free why would they
do that
right what is the request what is the
creator's benefit in giving something
away for what appears to be free this is
a uniquely a uniquely crypto element
virtual currencies benefit from network
effects the more people that actually
have and use a particular coin the more
valuable each particular coin is not in
terms of sticker price but into sticker
sorry stock ticker value but in terms of
actual functionality if you have a
dollar and I don't accept dollars all I
accept is
and no one around you no one around you
accepts dollars that dollar is well it's
not very functional is it it has no
utility if I accept dollars and you
accept dollars that dollar becomes
marginally more useful because you might
be able to pay me with it but I mean why
do I even accept dollars if some third
person over here across the room isn't
going to accept it from me right so the
more people that the more the more
people that actually use these things
the more people that want to use them in
commerce and know how to use them in
commerce and have experience using them
in commerce the more valuable they are
so if you're a crypto creator you can
benefit from these network effects that
drive the adoption it drives the actual
functional use of your token I have no
idea what happens to the price in an
airdrop no nobody at blockchain really I
would assume nobody blockchain really
doesn't it's not really the point anyway
this isn't for speculators this is for
people who want to get their first bit
of crypto so they can settle up a tab at
the bar or pay for lunch or settle a bet
or put in for a poker game or do all the
things that you do with money
and one of the one of the nice things is
that you know decentralization has
become a very powerful thing and when
just a few people have a particular
crypto it's not very decentralized
airdrops
blockchain airdrops can be a tool to
drive decentralization because each of
our users has a private key yeah it's a
I wrote about this today it's this
debate between decentralization and
centralization right and I think that
the crypto community especially young
Twitter and stuff whenever something
happens everyone you know decentralized
decentralized and they start screaming
about it and the point I was trying to
make when I frightened this was look
centralization is not inherently bad
right and I would actually argue that
many of the most popular internet
companies of today would not be as
successful as they are if they hadn't
been decentralized when they started
right so there was no I SEOs there was
no cryptocurrency there's no air drug
all of these elements did not exist and
so you needed a centralized team with a
centralized focus a centralized office
all these things to build the initial
network effect that then recive look at
a Facebook or Twitter you know Google
etc today actually a lot of these
projects are starting out with some sort
of centralized organization right and in
that organization as an illegal entity
but there's a group of people that come
together and they're organizing
themselves and their resources to create
something and then what decentralization
is really kind of proliferating as is
their ability to go from highly
centralized to quickly dissipate out or
distribute out their resources and their
workload to as many people as possible
right and so it's almost like there's a
spectrum and they start out and somewhat
of a centralized manner because you've
gotta organize those resources you've
got to organize ideas you got to build
something and then as quickly as you can
if you can decentralize yourself in your
organization that's where value is
accruing right yeah what do you think
about that well I think that so
decentralization has acquired this sort
of talismanic power in the industry
somewhat for a good reason somewhat for
good reason it's a term of art in the
law now
in fact decentralized convertible
virtual currencies as the Department of
the Treasury categorizes Bitcoin have
different regulatory overhead in fact
much lower regulatory overhead than
centralized convertible virtual currency
systems like PayPal it's interesting
right centralized convertible virtual
currency system Bitcoin is a
decentralized convertible virtual
currency system there is a money
transmitter there must be a money
transmitter who requires licenses who
requires registration achieve compliance
officer an AML policy kose etcetera this
was the kind of law that I practiced
right at at PayPal there has to be one
of those but at Bitcoin well there's no
Bitcoin Inc right there's nobody to do
that because it is sufficiently
decentralized so in in the money
services law decentralization there so
there's a very good reason why it's
become talismanic because it is now a
term of art interesting and it's the
same way we just we just saw the
the director of the division of
corporation finance at SEC Hill Hanneman
he said look there's there's actually
kind of a set of traps you can run on
your on your offering to tell whether
it's a security and what is the bar call
what is the line called decentralization
is your network decentralized enough as
it sufficiently does decentralized to
not be a security and so not only the
money services law but in the context of
the securities law if the if the network
is decentralized then it is it is less
likely or maybe just not a security so
the power of an airdrop of at least the
way of a blockchain air-dropped the way
that we do it is that it can really
Drive those effects it can drive those
decentralization affect those network
effects so that if you're a crypto
creator this is something that you
should be really attractive a bunch of
people who really don't have a whole lot
of incentive to speculate on your
current on your currency or to grow your
coin or whatever it is but have a lot of
tools available to use it that's that's
that's the power that we see in it let's
say that air drops become the de-facto
way to bootstrap Network effects right
so creators are building products
services companies networks etc that
they're gonna use these air drops to
distribute some sort of asset and really
get people to use it right does it
become saturated at some point right
every day I'm receiving a new airdrop
and I don't know
you know Monday from Tuesday and now
listen I've just got all this what looks
like free money or you know kind of spam
email yeah right like are you worried
that we get into a world where there's
not enough kind of skin in the game
maybe for the users right and it's too
frictionless or do you think that kind
of the best projects rise to the top and
and users will be attracted to just
understand that and kind of buy into the
network effects I think that's a really
good point and it's something that we've
struggled with at blockchains sort of it
what is the macro consequence if this
really catches on it's something that we
struggled with for the saft project
framework - right
of the consequences with it well maybe
people can't do icos anymore if this
thing really if this thing really picks
up yeah and with regard to air drops
like we're not trying to kill anything
with air drops or even become a market
standard for that matter but what what
what we have done is well a little bit
of curation right I don't think we first
see this as a tool as I don't think we
foresee this as every day some weird
worthless new piece of spam hits your
wallet because we have to do integration
work right yes first of all there's a
limiting factor but also we have users
that really have never heard of any RC
20 token right most of them don't know
about ICS they just think this is this
might be a better way to use their money
and so it's it's it's should come as no
surprise that we started off with
something that we believed to be a high
quality asset something that we think
can be good money something that is
built to scale that works even when
there's millions of people using a
network at the same time something that
you can actually create cool things with
you can build assets on top of stellar I
I don't see us doing this for every
project that comes along the way right
this is this is not like a tool for like
revenue generation for us we'd like I
said we don't we don't take any listing
fees so we're not just trying to like
jam a bunch of crypto down are you you
know down a users throat at the same
time we do want this to be a platform
for discovery so that if you don't know
a whole lot about crypto but you know
that everybody that you trust and
respect is said this stuff is amazing
you can open a blockchain wallet and
occasionally you'll find something new
and exciting in it that you can use
really you can really functionally use
it and give it a try yeah I mean to some
degree right people will associate the
quality of blockchain the company with
the quality of the things that get
through right and get air-dropped to
them etc and so there's a little bit of
you guys need to pay attention Yeah
right
okay so let's obscures a little bit and
I will make one final point on that go
ahead and that's that if every single
coin we airdrop ends up being like a
high quality asset that everybody uses
every day well no we've failed okay
why it means we haven't pushed the
envelope we're not we're like this
company doesn't exist so that we so that
people don't experience anything new and
and have to think out and never have to
think outside of the box I never get
confronted with something that changes
the way they think about money this
company exists to push that envelope
mm-hmm and so if we never deliver it
even one token then even one coin that
doesn't really take off well no we
played it too safe yeah I think it's
super interesting and very similar the
way venture capitalists think right even
though the companies go to zero you
actually failed there you go right
all right let's switch gears and talk
about asset tokenization right so I
think that you you've really helped and
been kind of integral part of these
crypto entrepreneurs funding network
growth and and these decentralized
organizations and a whole bunch of stuff
there I think what's become a popular
narrative right and you know we are big
proponents of it ourselves is taking
assets stocks bonds currencies and
commodities and digitizing them or or
tokenizing them on to blockchains
what's your personal view on you know
that market how it will if at all kind
of grow and where we're going there this
is a great other side of the coin firm
what we were talking about no pun
intended well it's actually a bad
Express it's a great foil it's a great
whatever it's it's it's it's the
opposite I'm not I'm just a lawyer I'm
not I'm not good with words the so what
you're talking about as opposed to Curt
cryptocurrencies and utility tokens is
tokenized securities right there are
investment products that are intended to
be investment products it's not a
question of ogle
it's gonna pass the Howey test no I we
know the thing is a security was always
intended to be one except instead of
writing it into Carta or writing it into
a my staple database or onto a stock
certificate we wrote it into a smart
contract on a blockchain those things
are tokenized securities they don't
benefit from network effects and as much
as they are tokenized securities we see
some weird hybrid things out there but
so much is they're just meant to
represent a share in a company it
doesn't matter how many people use the
network that represents the share in the
company the value doesn't come from the
network it comes from the performance of
the issuer and the efforts of the issuer
right to use the halle language I think
those are powerful for a different
reason and what we're going to see is
that in in in my opinion what we'll
probably see is that the tokens that
really capitalize on the the tokenized
securities I should say they're really
capitalized on the blockchain
infrastructure are the ones that
investors will see value and and we're
you know we don't air drop those right
we don't airdrop tokenized securities
it's it's it's it's it's not part of our
mission but I did a lot of work on this
when I was in private practice in fact I
was the that the the blockchain
ambassador to the state of Delaware in
in connection with the Delaware
blockchain initiative where we actually
amended the Delaware General Corporation
law to permit her to at least clarify
that corporations could use a blockchain
as their books and records so they could
rely on the contents and blockchain as
it has their books and records which is
kind of bonkers when you think about it
but that's
so first of all I didn't know that we
had a Delaware State Law celebrity in
here well but but you said it's bonkers
right and I push back on that in this
sense of today the books and records are
usually kept by the company they're
periodically audited by some third party
and external parties so you know
investors analysts researchers the
general public make decisions based on a
couple of things one the information
that is provided by the company which is
usually dictated by some sort of law or
rabbit or guidance to that the auditors
are correctly and accurately auditing
that information and representing it as
fact and then three is that nothing
changes or nothing material has changed
since the last either guidance given by
the company report given by the company
or audit right so kind of it there's no
real-time information there's no kind of
third party
immutable record of truth right all the
things that we know the blockchain
promises wouldn't it make sense though
that if you're eight external third
party and you say I trust no one you
would want that immutable record right
you would want that those books and
records held somewhere that you could
self audit it right you didn't have to
rely on other people or take on that
counterparty risk yeah and there's a
great example of that in the dole foods
case which is a piece of law it's a it's
a decision in the Delaware Chancery
Court back to Delaware in the in the
Delaware Chancery Court where the
company had requests for redemptions of
like thousands and thousands of more
shares than they actually had record
owners on their books okay so so explain
it so dole had given out share shorter
sold shares in the company whatever the
number was and they wrote that down and
their books and records saying you know
what was she eating ten thousand right
they'd given out ten thousand shares
that they had articulated in their books
and records and at some point in the
future more than ten thousand share
requests basically came back right and
so there was a mismatch between with the
books and records internally were
representing versus what people were
showing up to almost a run on the bank
to something through you know saying hey
give us this back how does that happen
that that's right you have to ask why
what possible scenario could lead to
that I mean I can pay a chicken farmer
using a lightning
work payment with my Bitcoin to dispense
corn feed to the chickens in Australia
from New York but dole foods can't keep
track of how many owners it has that's
crazy
and if in reality in the world we live
in that's not crazy that's how the net
settlement system in a public markets
and securities works that's that's how
this system of securities entitlement
work so for example how many people in
this room own a share of publicly traded
stock raise your hand now putting those
four people in the room it's not that
much but they all raise their hands
you don't you actually don't you are not
the owner of that stock there's a
company called C D in Kelvin o them that
owns that stock they are the nominee and
you have a securities entitlement you
have this subordinated right to that
stock and in between you and the issuer
there are a dozen intermediaries that
can lose track of things and just so
people really understand what you're
describing here would it be fair to kind
of simplify the complexity between the
issuer and the individual investor who
believes they own that stock as really
what they have is a lien on somebody
else's ownership of the stock I mean
it's it's it's called an entitlement
mmm-hmm right it's you know a lien is
you're asking a lawyer to be technical
the technically it's not a lien but the
idea is that I'm getting I'm getting the
Delaware State Law celebrity yeah to
give me lessons now definitely I am
absolutely not not the expert I I was I
was lucky enough to be involved in the
single project but you know the idea is
that you you have a right to what your
broker has your broker has a right to
what maybe some other broker has who all
the way up the chain has a right to this
share that is actually owned on the
books and records of the corporation by
the Depository Trust & Clearing
Corporation technically by CD and Co its
nominee and that happened back in the
paper and the paper Blizzard of the
1960s 1970s when stock when the markets
had to shut down in the middle of the
day because people just had to keep up
they had to keep up with with with
recording the transfer of these
securities
finally the street said look enough is
enough let's set let's set up what set
up a new process and there were two
alternatives one was a distributed
ledger I was just gonna say that's
basically what in the 70s it's solving
the double spent problem it could have
it could have but the technology just
wasn't there yet right just like with
uber right in the in the 90s we we were
talking about this before we got on the
on the mic but you know back in the 90s
we tell our kids not to take rides from
strangers getting don't get into cars
with strangers and now you literally you
pay a stranger to come in to give don't
talk to strangers on the internet don't
even right right because the technology
changed yep and and now we have
technology that actually allows that
that actually allows people to all join
this distributed ledger so you don't
have to have a small group of people
that are permitted to write mm-hmm to a
ledger that are that are permitted to
trade entitlements back and forth are
nets settle between their clients yeah
the the hyperbole statement that we
usually use is you know everyone talks
about crypto and blockchain as it's
risky right it's new it's unproven and
we make the argument a lot of times to
especially older CIOs look this is
actually less risky right and less and
and they kind of shrink back a little
what do you mean how could you say that
and you start walking them through it
and and because they're so deep in the
nuances of underwriting risk and things
like that they actually very quickly
come up to speed and to say oh you know
what this is very interesting right a
piece of technology can reduce my
counterparty risk it can really give me
true ownership of the asset right and
kind of what are the ramifications of
that I think becomes attractive and so
it's this whole idea that they just
gotta get educated Yeah right what's
they get educated then they start to
believe right and you get back to the
hole the virus is spreading and all that
stuff cool so let me ask this one of the
things we've talked about on previous
episodes with folks is you know as we
get deeper and deeper down the rabbit
hole and talk to people across the
industry one theme that continues to
emerge is what if we're actually under
estimating the potential of blockchain
Bitcoin crypto
currency right and I think most of us
who are excited about this have you know
dedicated parts of our careers to
working on it we have high ambitions or
believe in that in the prospects of the
technology what's like the farthest
outer most extreme view of this industry
that you could see or believe in well
you know this is this has sort of become
this has sort of become hackneyed at
this point but when we think when when
when the first internet pioneers were
were doing their work they were they
thought oh my gosh we are going to be
able to send a single packet of data and
it's gonna make its way all the way
around the world one day and I don't I
don't know who among them really
envisioned you know billions of those
packets of data being sent around the
world in I don't know the numbers in a
second I mean we we we don't we didn't
think of that we never understand the
the holistic impact of new technologies
like this I think that we like saying
how impactful they're going to be what
when asked for an application this is
where the venture capitalists in
particular are you know are successful
because they can predict the future but
most of us can't and when I look at
crypto today I see people amazed when
they when they use their first bit of
crypto this is why we're giving away
twenty five bucks to somebody so they
can just try it so they can so they can
move crypto around the world in the
blink of an eye when I when I see the
magic in people's eyes when they do that
and they're shocked that it worked I
think how shocked are they going to be
when that little bit of value is no more
special or unique than a packet of data
that runs across the internet and people
are sending not just individuals but
machines or sending are sending money
sending value around the world in as
frictionless and liquid away as people
send generic data today I I don't fully
understand the consequences of that
you know you can think of the sort of
the examples that are now somewhat
overused have the the car pulling up to
the gas station and the car
independently of you settling up with
the gas station owner in some form of
cryptocurrency maybe it's stellar
excellent maybe it's Bitcoin and you
know that that seems like a very basic
example of one day maybe we'll be able
to send a packet of data all the way
around the world who knows what life is
gonna be like when well money yeah is is
being sent around those packets we we
talk a lot about blockchain and crypto
has to happen for automation to actually
work right so if you think of this idea
of in an automated world you're gonna
get machines that have to trust other
machines and so what better way to do
that than in a fully transparent machine
driven or how are the algorithmically
driven world and so going back to
acitivities ation if you get every stock
bond currency and commodity that ends up
being tokenize or digitized you now
unlock the potential for things that you
and I probably can't even comprehend or
imagine yeah it's like email is just a
faster letter right you know kind of but
nobody really realized that we would be
you know how how it would just
fundamentally change the way that we do
business
absolutely all right so let's go into a
kind of a quick round of questions and
then we'll we'll end up with you asking
me one question but what do you think is
the most important company in crypto
outside of watching the most important
company yeah if you'd pick one other
than where you work what's the most
important company right now oh gosh
that's a good question
CloudFlare cloud fair okay why well they
control the websites you get to see it's
that simple it's it's it's true it's
truly it's truly that simple they are
the gatekeepers to the web in the same
way that
Google is the gatekeeper to email like
there are no websites there's just what
CloudFlare stops DDoS is against there
is no email there is just what Google
allows to get through it spam filters
interesting we have never had anyone who
who has thought that way has a really
good one okay what is if you had a magic
wand and you could wave it and change
any one regulation or improve any one
regulation what would it be and use this
I ask everybody's question but I'm
really interested in what your your
opinion is these are hard you didn't
tell me about any of these before
that's before I got part of the game I
would I would harmonize investor
protection regulations around the world
interesting I wouldn't know how to do it
yep I wouldn't do it if I could snap my
fingers and do it believe me I I would
have but it's something that lawyers
struggle against constantly it's
something that I know regulators
struggle against constantly and
entrepreneurs in the space that is that
is the one question on all of their
minds is how do I actually execute this
thing I just want to do a Kickstarter
like issuance but is it a security is it
not and you're talking about each
jurisdiction has different laws
protections regulations etc and some of
them are consistent some of them are
interpretive very frank they're out of
step and you know I've been I've been
working with policymakers and regulators
and cryptos since 2013 and if there's
one thing I've found is that it is an
uneven landscape it is it isn't
incredibly uneven landscape regulators
in and legislators in the United Kingdom
for example don't always even know what
the law is in the United States and part
of that is because we in the United
States don't even really know what the
law is and it's this it's this it's this
stutter start it's a sort of punctuated
hurry up and stop approach to creating
new regulations where when one
jurisdiction juts out ahead but not too
far and they're a little bit wishy-washy
on it but that kind of sets a little bit
of a precedent another jurisdiction goes
out
they'll say a little bit of you know
they'll they'll they'll put their own
take on it but they won't commit and
then depending on with a third and
fourth and fifth people do there's some
equilibrium reached but then someone
steps a little bit further like what
happened in the bitlicense in New York
so it's punctuated mm-hmm
two more questions what's the one
thought you have our belief in crypto
that you think majority of other people
would disagree with you the one thought
I have in oh so in unpopular crypto
exactly an unpopular crypto opinion oh
wow everyone in crypto is not short on
the unpopular opinions but what's the
one that you like really believe in that
you think most other people would
respect no way hmm that is a difficult
one
how much hemming and hawing can I do
that you'll edit out at the end of this
I'd take a little bit I can make you
think a little bit longer you could
think yeah look the bottom line is I
feel like all I've all have had her
unpopular opinions you know people
didn't like what what we said in the
staff project framework at least some
people didn't like it right because they
called out a lot of people for doing
things they probably shouldn't been
doing is that the one thing that you
think you've been involved in where it
felt like there was the most pushback I
think that's I think that's probably
fair to say I think that's probably fair
to say who knows if air drops will be
something like that I we hope not I mean
we're giving people free stuff to try to
actually you know get into crypto for
the first time and use it and the risks
are pretty low there but you know when
we published this half project white
paper there are a lot of people who had
just done icos and some people whose
whole business model was built on doing
ICS and they didn't they didn't take it
well yeah so yeah there were
consequences doesn't mean you're right
doesn't mean you're wrong right all
right and so uh last question not crypto
related but I'm excited to talk about
this one because we've had big
developments in the alien space so I
usually ask everybody mwah mwah mwah
what is it that I always say yeah if if
aliens are real right do you think
there's alien pets right we always think
of aliens as like a human-like creature
no one ever talks about are they showing
up off the spaceship with
with dogs and cats and you know other
forms of life that are pets
absolutely there's episode of Star Trek
about this I feel like I how am i the
nerdiest person in the room of course
everybody every all the aliens in Star
Trek mm-hmm right they mostly look like
each other two arms two legs yep two
eyes one nose because well life always
kind of evolves in the same way so yeah
of course they're gonna have pets just
like we do now maybe they got a little
farther along the spectrum and the pets
aren't allowed on the spaceships yet
because Hale didn't even have spaceships
well there you go you got my sci-fi
thought for of the year well well so
here's the thing right I'm shocked at
how few people are talking about the
spaceship and for those that I don't
know the head of the astrology
department at Harvard you say astrology
or I'm sorry man it has been a long day
well it could some people probably shoot
apart if he's talking about aliens maybe
but but what do you came out he said
right well is that look there is this I
didn't know we caught what interstellar
object I think is what they're calling
it yeah that was picked up by a bunch of
telescopes and the way that it moved it
accelerated in kind of a weird way it
was shaped in a weird way and he's
basically saying listen this may have
been some sort of transportation vehicle
where an alien species was actually
sending it to look at earth come near
Earth etcetera Harvard professor right
how far in the left-field spectrum are
we getting there with the but he said
that one he's a professor of astrology
so I don't I don't I don't all right so
I and each episode with letting the
guests ask me one question what one
question do you have for me when did you
open your blockchain wallet when did I
open my blockchain wallet so I've got
two answers to this one is the first
thing I actually did which in hindsight
was really dumb was I actually turned on
a cryptocurrency mining rig first
nothing attached to it and so we plugged
it in and we didn't know right we were
like what are we doing here and so
plugged it in then okay then we get a
wallet right then once you get the
tokens into the wallet what do you do
with it how do I go back to Fiat and so
the way that I actually got into crypto
was my my business partner and I had
both invested in he and he was running a
power company and so it takes car tires
it puts it into a reactor burnt the car
tires and turns it into oil steel carbon
and sin gas but it's company called PRT
I and so it sells the oil and the steel
as a commodity and takes the carbons and
gas turns it into power and was supposed
to sell the power into the grid we
started learning about cryptocurrency
mining we said hey we've got really
advantageous economics of power we
should actually just build crypto mines
and so I had bought a rig plug didn't
had no clue what I was doing right and
and kind of worked our way through the
whole ecosystem and it wasn't until plug
the machines oh we actually probably
should capture one like me right do that
then once you get into the wallet how do
I get it onto an exchange I'm in
exchange how do I get into Fiat right
you know I mean literally every mistake
along the way which in hindsight makes
you feel good that if you could figure
it out and you're that dumb to start
like anyone can do this but that was in
in 2016 and and I think that I'm so
thankful that that's how we came across
this stuff was because it was at the
kind of true essence of how the block
chains work what's the value and to your
point I think with these air drops right
it's most people experience it right
whether it's you air dropped me
something and I can use it or it's back
at 2013 when you guys are sitting there
doing a presentation for federal
regulators saying here's a wallet
address we're gonna take some
cryptocurrency we're gonna send it to a
new wall to address its appeared in the
new one right just the visual unlocking
or the experience of actually doing it I
think just gets people hooked right and
definitely did it for me
and and so him and I always get a good
laugh at it we still got a picture
that's pretty
you know outrageous in terms of the
first mines we built like that but yes
2016 right on awesome man thank you so
much for coming this is uh this is super
super helpful on I think you got a
unique perspective so we're cheering for
you guys and hopefully we'll do this
again thanks for having me